Hallo Manuel.
Hallo Cari.
Und hallo Gast. Hallo Klaus!
Hallo! Ich wäre hier gerade fast ausgerutscht.
Das, das ist ja mal ein Entrance, wollte ich
sagen, ein Eintritt in die Sendung, Klaus.
Wo sehen wir dich denn da?
Das ist das Arbeitszimmer, wo ich gerade bin.
Ja, das Arbeitszimmer, da kommen wir gleich
zu, wie das Arbeitszimmer eingerichtet ist.
Manuel, wir sprechen heute zum ersten Mal
in unserem Podcast über ein Thema, mit dem
du dich — ganz öffentlich bekannt — gar
nicht auskennst.
Richtig, ja.
Und deswegen mussten wir heute einen Experten
einladen, der nämlich unser beider Unwissen
ausgleichen kann. Und das ist unser guter
Freund Klaus. Willkommen, Klaus.
Hallo! Danke, dass ich da sein kann. Zumindest
habe ich ein bisschen mehr Wissen als ihr.
Ob ich ein Experte bin, weiß ich nicht.
Ja, das reicht schon, ne? Wir haben ja gar
kein Wissen, du hast viel Wissen. Klaus, du
bist heute zum ersten Mal nicht in der Rolle
des Lehrers hier, sondern als Fußballfan
mit Lehrhintergrund, mit Lehrauftrag. Du wirst
uns also einiges erklären können. Wie geht
es dir denn heute?
Ich wollte grad sagen, also doch wieder Lehrer,
mit Lehrauftrag.
Am Ende bist du einfach immer der Lehrer.
Ja. Nee, mir geht es sehr gut, danke. Ich
hoffe, euch auch.
Wir haben gesehen, dass du dein Arbeitszimmer
… also normalerweise ist das so ein typisches
Lehrer-Arbeitszimmer, was du da hast. Heute
Morgen hatten wir einen Test Call, da waren
da noch Bücher. Und was sehen wir jetzt?
Ja, ich habe jetzt so ziemlich viele Schals
und Trikots, die ich noch gefunden habe, aufgehangen
(aufgehängt).
Schön.
Für verschiedene Vereine, das ist interessant.
Ja, die haben natürlich alle eine Geschichte,
warum ich die habe, aber es sind zwei Vereine,
die deutlich erkennbar dominieren. Das ist
einmal Schwarz-Gelb …
Der SV Me…
BVB.
Genau. Und Blau-Weiß, SV Meppen, genau, ja.
Das ist also dein Heimatverein, der SV Meppen.
Ja. Und dann können wir doch auch direkt
anfangen, oder? Mit unserem heutigen …
Wir reden heute tatsächlich über ein Thema,
was sehr populär ist in Deutschland. Außer
bei Manuel und mir, deswegen ist Klaus dabei.
Und Klaus, du hast dir was überlegt zum Einstieg.
Ja genau. Ich habe gedacht, wir machen am
Anfang mal ein kurzes Quiz, einige Fragen
zum Thema Fußball, unterschiedliche Schwierigkeiten
aber. Und ich gebe euch aber jedes Mal drei
Antwortmöglichkeiten vor, sodass ihr nicht
ganz im Dunkeln tappen müsst.
Unsere Zuschauer da draußen: Hallo, liebe
Grüße an unsere YouTube Live-Zuschauer.
Ihr könnt auch mitraten und in die Kommentare
eure Antwort schreiben.
Ja, dann fange ich mal an. Erste Frage, es
geht um einen sehr berühmten Fußballer aus
Argentinien, ich glaube, ihr kennt alle: Diego
Maradona. (Maradona!) Genau, so, richtige
Antwort. Nein, die Frage ist folgende, und
zwar: Der ist, 1982 ist er nach Europa gewechselt
von einem argentinischen Verein, Boca Juniors,
und hat dort dann für welchen Verein zunächst
gespielt? Wo ist er hingewechselt? Ist es
SSC Neapel, Barcelona oder Madrid?
Also ich habe direkt an Barcelona gedacht,
wahrscheinlich war er da am Ende und nicht
am Anfang, aber ich ich sage einfach mal Barcelona.
Ich sage Neapel.
Und Manuel hat recht. Ein Punkt für Manuel.
Wahnsinn! Es war Barcelona.
Geil.
Total geraten. (Nee.) Von uns beiden. Nö.
Es kommt jetzt direkt die Anschlussfrage,
und zwar, der hat dann direkt im Anschluss,
als er dorthin gewechselt ist, im Spätsommer,
Herbst '82, sein erstes Spiel gemacht für
den FC Barcelona. Gegen wen und wo hat es
stattgefunden? War es gegen den Bayern, gegen
Bayern München in München, war es gegen
Inter Mailand in Mailand oder war es in Meppen
gegen den SV Meppen?
Ich sage A.
Klaus, das sind aber ja keine Anfängerfragen,
das sind ja total die Profifragen heute.
So ein bisschen zum Warmwerden.
Okay, dann sage ich auch A.
Ja, es war aber der SV Meppen.
Was? (Echt?)
Ja. Es war natürlich ein Testspiel zum siebzigjährigen
Vereinsjubiläum und der SV Meppen hat sich
für damals, glaube ich, siebzigtausend Mark
den FC Barcelona eingekauft und es war halt
das erste Spiel von Maradona auf europäischem
Boden.
Sag doch mal, SV Meppen, ist das so, ist das
ein bekannter Verein in Deutschland? Welche
Liga spielt der?
Nee, die spielen in der dritten Liga, die
waren früher auch schon mal in der zweiten
Liga und ja, sind, ich sage mal, Kennern,
die sich so ein bisschen mit Bundesliga und
so weiter beschäftigen, die kennen den SV
Meppen, aber ist natürlich schon ein Regionalverein.
Wir nicht, ja.
Gut, die nächste Frage ist aber ein bisschen
leichter, glaube ich. Es gibt natürlich viele
schöne Stadien in Deutschland. Was ist denn
in der Bundesliga auf jeden Fall das größte
Stadion? Ist es das in Dortmund, ist es das
in München oder ist es das in Berlin?
Das weiß ich zufällig. Aha, warte mal. Ja
doch, ich weiß das, weil ich habe dort eine
Besichtigung gemacht und das ist das Dortmunder
Stadion.
Ja. (Cari?) Ich glaube, dass es das auch ist,
weil ich das mal gehört habe. Eigentlich,
von der Größe her denkt, würde man denken,
das in Berlin ist größer, aber ich sage
auch Dortmund. Neunzigtausend oder so?
Ja, nicht ganz so viele, aber über zweiundachtzigtausend,
genau. Es ist … mit Stehplätzen natürlich,
das ist klar. In der Champions League wird
auf Sitzplätze zurückgebaut, dann sind es
nicht ganz so viele. Wir bleiben bei Stadien
und das ist jetzt eine Frage, da muss man
raten, das kann man nicht wissen: Welcher
Stadion… oder welchen Stadionnamen gibt
es in Deutschland wirklich? Ist es die "Schauinsland"-Arena,
ist es das "Check24"-Stadion oder es ist das
"Teddybären und Plüsch"-Stadion?
A.
Ich tippe B, weil so viel mit Sponsoring und
so gemacht wird heutzutage und dann hat Check24
da bestimmt Geld für bezahlt.
Cari hat diesmal den Punkt gewonnen. Es ist
die Schauinsland-Reisen-Arena in Duisburg.
Check24 gibt es wirklich nicht, aber die (das)
"Teddybären und Plüsch"-Stadion, das gab
es mal tatsächlich für wenige Spieltage
in Österreich, in Wien. Und da hat ein Sponsor
sich diese Namensrechte für sieben Spieltage
bei einer Tombola gewonnen und na ja, dann
hieß es halt so.
Und das Beste draus gemacht.
Das Beste draus gemacht, den schönsten Namen
einfach gegeben, den man haben kann. Apropos
Namen, die nächste Frage geht jetzt um Namen:
Welche Spieler gab es oder gibt es wirklich?
Einmal Lorenzo Carotti, Adigun Salami und
Dustin Wurst.
Ich sage A. Das klingt für mich nach einem
guten Namen.
Ich sage C.
C. Ja, das war eine Fangfrage: Es gibt sie
alle wirklich, ne? Also es ist eine schöne
Zusammenstellung von Essen. Genau. Jetzt eine
Schätzfrage: Ihr kennt ja alle einen Fußball,
wie der aussieht, ne? Und der besteht ja aus
Fünfecken und Sechsecken, die so aneinandergenäht
sind. Wie viele Fünfecke und Sechsecke sind
es insgesamt? Sind es vierzehn, sechsundzwanzig
oder zweiunddreißig? So ein handelsüblicher
Fußball. Ich sehe, ihr rechnet im Kopf durch,
geht die geometrischen Figuren durch.
Nee. Ich will nur warten, dass Cari zuerst
antwortet.
B.
26. (Ich sage 32.) Es sind 32, genau. Sehr
schön, ja.
Yes. Zwei zu eins für mich. Ich zähle mit.
Genau.
Manuel, was für ein Glück für dich!
Ja. Jetzt eine Frage, die unseren Bundespräsidenten
betrifft. Der hat nämlich in seiner Jugend
… also Frank-Walter Steinmeier, der hat
in seiner Jugend auch mal Fußball gespielt
und hat dann einen Spitznamen bekommen, die
wohl mit seiner Spielweise auf dem Platz zusammenhing.
Und ich gebe euch mal drei mögliche Spitznamen
vor: Wurde er "Prickel" genannt, wurde er
"Acker" genannt oder wurde er "Terrier" genannt?
B.
Wow. Ich sage C: Terrier.
Ja, es war die "Prickelnadel", der Frank-Walter.
Der Acker, das war, glaube ich, Gerhard Schröder,
wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung hatte.
Der wurde, der wurde immer Acker genannt,
der ehemalige Bundeskanzler.
Terrier ist er auf jeden Fall nicht. Das ist
ja gar nicht sein, seine Art.
Nein, nee. Der sticht mit scharfen Worten.
Was macht denn ein Prickel?
Das ist ja, das ist so eine Prickelnadel,
mit de(r) man so zum Beispiel beim Basteln
Sachen ausprickeln kann. Ja, also, mein Finger
ist ein bisschen krumm, aber, ne?
Ich kenne das Wort gar nicht.
Prickeln? Nee? Manuel, kennst du das Wort?
Nee, aber haben jetzt auch unsere Zuschauer
gelernt.
Ja, wird nicht oft benutzt, aber ich habe
es schon mal gehört, ja.
Genau. Ja, ich habe noch eine Frage, eine
aktuelle Frage, und zwar: Im November gab
es ein Champions League-Spiel in Dortmund,
und zwar Borussia Dortmund gegen den FC Brügge.
Und da konnte der Top Stürmer Emmanuel Dennis
nicht mitspielen, aber warum konnte er nicht
mitspielen? A: Er hat sich in der Woche vor
dem Spiel ein Tattoo stechen lassen und konnte
wegen der Corona-Auflagen, weil er die verletzt
hatte, dann nicht mitspielen. Er ist beim
Warmmachen im Rasen hängen geblieben mit
dem Fuß, hat sich so verletzt, dass er auch
nicht dann mitspielen konnte. Oder: Er wollte
auf der Hinfahrt im Bus auf seinem Lieblingsplatz
sitzen, der war aber schon besetzt und dann
ist er wieder aus dem Bus ausgestiegen.
A. Ich sage mal A.
Ich sage auch A. Ich meine auch, dass …
Es war C. Er hat im Bus seinen Lieblingsplatz
nicht bekommen. Dann gab es Streit und dann
ist er ausgestiegen und dann hat die Vereinsführung
gesagt: "Okay, dann bleibst du zu Hause".
Und dann sind sie ohne ihn …
So kennen wir den BVB.
Na, es war ja der FC Brügge, aber …
Ach so, die waren das.
Genau. Das war ein Spieler vom FC Brügge,
genau. Ja gut. Das vielleicht so ein bisschen
zum Warmwerden.
Manuel, ich möchte dir offiziell gratulieren.
(Vielen Dank.) Du hast dieses Fußball-Quiz
gewonnen …
Ganz unverdient.
… mit deinem scharfen Sachverstand. Niemand
konnte damit rechnen. Wie sieht es denn eigentlich
bei euch aus? Ich möchte mal mit euch darüber
reden, was so, wie das Fußballleben in Deutschland
so aussieht und was für einen Stellenwert
Fußball in Deutschland hat. In Manuels Leben
spielt das aktuell keine große Rolle, aber
viele Deutsche sind ja schon Fußballfans.
Wie war das denn früher bei euch als Kind?
Habt ihr früher als Kind Fußball gespielt?
Ja. Ich war immer schlecht und hatte immer
auch nicht so Lust, muss ich sagen und wollte
dann am liebsten ins Tor, weil da musste man
nicht so viel rennen, aber andererseits auch
ein bisschen gefährlich im Tor, also, aber
klar. Als Kind spielt man in Deutschland Fußball,
also, weiß ich gar nicht, ja.
Und du, Klaus?
Ja, das kann ich bestätigen. Also ich habe
auch als Kind viel Fußball gespielt, auch
mal eine kurze Zeit im Verein, aber dann auch,
als ich nicht mehr im Verein gespielt habe,
haben wir uns oft getroffen auf dem Bolzplatz
und haben mit Freunden Fußball gespielt.
Drei gegen drei, vier gegen vier, auf kleine
Tore, ja.
Fünf gegen fünf. (Genau.) Das ist ein schönes
Wort, der Bolzplatz. Es gibt dieses Verb "bolzen".
Das bedeutet also, dass man … bedeutet das,
dass man auf eine bestimmte Art Fußball spielt
oder ist das einfach ein umgangssprachliches
Wort für Fußball spielen, bolzen? Oder ist
das was, was Kinder mehr machen, ne, bolzen?
Nee, das ist, also, bolzen ist, glaube ich,
einfach ein umgangssprachliches Wort für
Fußball spielen, aber eher in so einem informellen
Rahmen, ne, also nicht so im Verein.
Richtig. Man würde jetzt nicht sagen, "der
FC Bayern hat" … wenn man sagt, "der FC
Bayern hat rumgebolzt", dann würde das heißen,
dass sie nicht gut gespielt haben, oder?
Ja, ja, tatsächlich so. Also in dem Kontext
ja, aber genau, wenn man bolzen geht, dann
geht man einfach eine Runde kicken, einfach
spontan mit Freunden, das ist bolzen, ja.
(Gut Kick.) Genau. Gut Kick will Weile haben.
Ja, ich war früher, es wird euch vielleicht
überraschen, aber ich war eine begeisterte
Bolzerin. Ich habe auch auf vielen Bolzplätzen
gespielt. Unter anderem hatten wir hinter
unserem Haus ein Kloster und die hatten einen
Fußballplatz und da haben wir uns immer eingeschlichen
und dort Fußball gespielt und ich war richtig
begeistert damit (davon). Und irgendwann kam
mal ein Mädchenfußballverein und die wollten
unbedingt, dass ich für sie spiele. Ich hatte
aber keine Lust, weil ich wollte nur mit Jungs
spielen, weil da ging es immer ein bisschen
rauer zu. Und ich war dann auch zum Training
bei dem Fußballverein und die sind dann auch
extra noch mal zu meinen Eltern nach Hause
gekommen und haben gesagt: "Wäre schon schön,
wenn die Carina bei uns spielt." Aber dieser
Verein, das hat mich nicht begeistert. Ich
musste dann weiter draußen spielen und das
hat mich aber schon begeistert. Ich war auch
früher Fußballfan und das wäre jetzt meine
nächste Frage an euch: Es gibt ja so was
wie eine Vereinskultur in Deutschland und
eine Fankultur, also diese Fußballvereine
sind auch sehr identitätsstiftend, viele
Leute identifizieren sich mit einem Verein.
Mit welchem Verein identifiziert ihr euch
denn? Klaus hat es schon verraten. Manuel,
hast du auch einen Verein?
Also bei mir gab es da wenige, also es hat
sich ein paar Mal geändert. Ich war irgendwann
als Kind BVB-Fan, weil es so eine CD gab mit
den Liedern vom BVB und ich fand die Lieder
einfach gut und dann habe ich gesagt, dann
bin ich jetzt BVB-Fan. Und dann habe ich mir
das später aber anders überlegt, denn in
dem Dorf, in dem ich gewohnt habe als Kind,
da hat Olaf Thon, ein bekannter Fußballer
vom FC Schalke, gelebt mit seiner Familie.
Und da bin ich irgendwann mal mit einem Freund
vorbeigegangen und wir haben da einfach mal
geklingelt und haben uns ein Autogramm geholt
und dann hatte ich dieses Autogramm und dann
dachte ich, "okay, dann bin ich jetzt Schalke-Fan",
aber ich war nie auf irgendwelchen Fußballspielen
und habe mir das auch nie angeschaut. Also
ich war nie wirklich Fußballfan, nee.
Ja. Klaus, was sagst du dazu?
Ja, es ist ja auch vollkommen unvorstellbar,
dass man erst Dortmund-Fan ist und dann aufgrund
eines Autogramms dann zum FC Schalke überläuft.
Das kann ich mir auch nicht so richtig vorstellen.
(Geht eigentlich gar nicht.) Da ist es nicht
viel mit dem Fan-Sein.
Die sind, erklär das unseren Zuschauern,
die sind verfeindet. Kann man das so sagen?
Die beiden Clubs?
Ja, verfeindet. Auf jeden Fall ist da eine
gesunde Rivalität zwischen den beiden Vereinen,
ja. Das sind, die sind ja aus zwei Städten,
die relativ nah beieinander liegen und die
sind beide relativ erfolgreich in den letzten
Jahrzehnten gewesen, mit Höhen und Tiefen
natürlich. Und es hat sich da doch eine gute
und gesunde Rivalität, bei manchen vielleicht
auch Feindschaft, entwickelt, ja.
Also sagen wir mal so: Du und dein Bruder,
ihr geht ja gerne zum BVB ins Stadion. Wenn
dein Bruder jetzt ankäme und sagen würde:
"Klaus, ich gehe ab nächste Woche zu Schalke."
Was würdest du dann sagen?
Ich glaube, ich wüsste erst mal gar nicht,
was ich sagen würde. Da wäre ich erst mal
sehr baff. Das könnte ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Nein. Das, dieser Fall wird nicht mal hypothetisch
eintreten, Cari.
Okay, verstehe. Zurück zu deinen Stadion-Erfahrungen.
Klaus, wie oft gehst du denn ins Stadion zu
Borussia Dortmund?
So in letzter Zeit nicht mehr ganz so viel,
früher doch schon öfter. Ich hatte auch
mal eine Zeit lang, das war, ja, so im Studium
und später hatte ich auch mal eine Zeit lang
eine Dauerkarte, wo man dann tatsächlich
dann alle zwei Wochen da war. Ist in den letzten
Jahren leider ein bisschen weniger geworden,
aber das ist natürlich schon schön, wenn
man wirklich regelmäßig den Lieblingsverein
auch live sieht, nicht nur im Fernsehen, sondern
tatsächlich vor Ort. Das ist halt schon echt
eine tolle Erfahrung einfach.
Und warum? Das interessiert mich mal, also,
man ist doch dann quasi neunzig Minuten plus
Pause, also irgendwie zwei Stunden, steht
man, wenn man jetzt keinen Sitzplatz hat.
Es sind wahnsinnig viele Leute und man schreit
und man sieht aber ja eigentlich nicht viel,
also. Verkauf mir mal diese Experience. Warum
ist das so geil?
Ja, ich glaube, Experience ist da auch schon
das richtige Wort, weil es ist ja, es ist
ja nicht nur dieses neunzig Minuten auf der
Tribüne stehen, sondern es fängt ja an,
du freust dich auf das Spiel schon vorher,
verabredest dich mit deinen Freunden. Dann
fährst du zum Stadion zusammen mit anderen
Leuten hin, trinkst vielleicht auch schon
ein Bier auf dem Weg, redest ganz viel. Dann
trifft man sich vor dem Stadion, isst was,
trinkt was, dann geht man zusammen rein. Das
dauert natürlich mit Sicherheitsschleusen
und so weiter und dann geht man die Treppen
hoch, kommt in das Stadion rein. Es ist meistens
schon gut gefüllt. Es ist halt schon so ein
erhabenes Gefühl, wenn du dann einfach im
Stadion bist und fieberst dem Spiel entgegen.
Und es entsteht da halt wirklich so eine Dynamik
und die ist echt sehr faszinierend. Und ein
Spieltag ist dann quasi, man kann das vielleicht
vergleichen, ich hoffe, dass mir da niemand
böse ist, vielleicht mit so einer Messe,
mit so einem Ritual, weil das halt immer gleich
abläuft, ne? Man weiß, eine halbe Stunde
vor dem Spiel kommt die Mannschaft rein, läuft
sich warm mit der Musik und dann kommt das
und dann kommt das und dann kommt bei Dortmund
zumindest vor dem Spiel immer noch "You'll
Never Walk Alone". (Das Bier.) Es gibt das
Bier und je (nachdem), wie das Spiel läuft,
bist du gut drauf, bist mal kurz schlecht
drauf. Man lacht viel, man schreit, man regt
sich auf. Also es ist wirklich, das Gesamterlebnis
ist wirklich toll.
Ich glaube, das Stärkste ist auch dieses
Mitfiebern. Ich muss sagen, dass ich das,
ich war früher sehr starker Fußballfan.
Ich habe früher auch noch andere Sportarten
geguckt, von denen man nicht glaubt, dass
ich sie geguckt habe, aber zum Beispiel Formel
1. Ich bin dann auch manchmal nachts aufgestanden.
Und ich muss sagen, dieses Mitfiebern, dass
man quasi etwas sieht und das diese Emotionen
auf dich selber überträgt, dass du dann
dich total freust, Angst hast, sauer bist,
weil diesem, weil dieser Mannschaft irgendwas
Gutes oder Schlechtes passiert, das kann man
eigentlich auf wenig andere Kontexte übertragen,
so. Also ich finde, das ist eigentlich eine
schöne, ein schönes, identitätsstiftendes
Moment. Und ich glaube, das ist auch der Grund,
warum das viele Leute machen, weil man Teil
einer Gruppe ist und gemeinsam etwas fühlt.
Klaus, kann man das so sagen?
Ja natürlich. Das kann man so sagen. Also
das ist, man fühlt sich verbunden mit den
Menschen, mit dem Verein, mit dem Spiel. Und
es ist halt so, mal gewinnt man, mal verliert
man, ne? Das ist, das ist so. Das heißt,
man hat wirklich Glücksgefühle, man hat
aber auch sehr niederschmetternde Gefühle
manchmal und das, man erlebt zusammen immer
ganz viel und das zeichnet das halt aus. Cari,
willst du das wirklich anziehen?
Als ehemaliger Fan des FC Bayern hat man natürlich
viele Glücksmomente gehabt. Das ist mein
Original-Trikot von … ich weiß gar nicht,
wie alt das ist. Mindestens zwanzig Jahre
alt und das war damals die Nummer 18.
Jürgen Klinsmann, ja.
Kennt ihr den noch?
Auf jeden Fall.
Ja, klar.
Einer der berühmtesten Stürmer und ich habe
auch hier drauf damals Autogramme gesammelt.
Ich war dann tatsächlich in München beim
Training, ich habe Autogramme von Jürgen
Klinsmann bekommen auf mein Klinsmann-Trikot.
Was für ein Erlebnis! Klaus, hast du denn
ein Lieblingsspiel, was du mal … du hast
ja viele Spiele im Stadion gesehen. Gibt es
einen Lieblingsmoment, den du hattest?
Ja, gibt es. Also es gibt, sind natürlich
Spiele dabei gewesen, wo wir Deutscher Meister
geworden sind, 2011, 2012, also ich rede jetzt
von Borussia Dortmund. Oder das Champions
League-Finale 2013, wo wir dann aber am Ende
verloren haben gegen den FC Bayern. DFB-Finale,
DFB-Pokal-Finale, aber ein Spiel, das ist
wirklich mir total in Erinnerung geblieben.
Das war ein Champions League-Spiel gegen Málaga,
eine spanische Mannschaft, und das war das
Rückspiel im Viertelfinale und das war auch
2013 in der Saison, wo wir bis ins Finale
gekommen sind. Und da stand es in der neunzigsten
Minute eins zu zwei für den FC Málaga und
es gab vier Minuten Nachspielzeit. Und ich
stand mit meinem Bruder auf der Südbühne
ziemlich weit oben und es war irgendwie klar,
wir hat… man hatte erst acht Minuten vorher
das Gegentor, das letzte, bekommen, dass … wir
scheiden aus. Und dann war es aber so, dass
in der einundneunzigsten Minute Marco Reus
ein Tor gemacht hatte. Zwei zu zwei. Die Stimmung
kochte, das Stadion kochte und dann eine Minute
später hat Felipe Santana aus, glaube ich,
einer leicht abseitsverdächtigen Position
den Ball irgendwie ins Tor gestochert. Und
da ist das Stadion explodiert, ne? Also wirklich
alle haben so gejubelt und das war so ein
tolles Gefühl, das weiß ich noch ganz genau,
ja.
Ich habe etwas Ähnliches erlebt, auch im
Dortmund Stadion, aber ohne den BVB. Und zwar
war ich 2006 beim WM-Spiel Deutschland - Polen
live dabei, zusammen mit Isi. Und das war
auch ein unvergessenes Erlebnis, denn es war
tatsächlich so, dass in der neunzigsten Minute
das Eins-zu-Null getroffen wurde.
David Odonkor am rechten Flügel gelaufen,
Flanke in die Mitte und Oliver Neuville in
der Mitte reingehauen.
Klaus, du weißt einfach alles.
Ich war auch in Dortmund, aber ich war nicht
im Stadion, sondern ich war daneben in der
Westfalenhalle, weil ich keine Eintrittskarte
bekommen hatte. Also ich war wirklich nur
hundert, hundertfünfzig Meter von dir weg.
Echt? Damals kannten wir uns noch gar nicht?
(Nee.) Oder doch? Vielleicht schon. Stark,
Klaus. Wollen wir vielleicht ein paar Fragen
aus unserer Community beantworten? Es sind
schon einige gekommen.
Sehr gerne. (Klar.)
Das ist vielleicht, wäre vielleicht interessant.
Dann machen wir jetzt weiter mit …
Wir haben schon ein paar coole Fragen bekommen.
Und zwar fragt Mustafa: "Ist der RB Leipzig
von den Deutschen gehasst?" Klaus?
Ja, also so ganz pauschal kann man das natürlich
nicht sagen. Also, es gibt bestimmt Vereine,
die sind beliebter als RB Leipzig. Das liegt
da…
Erkläre uns, warum.
Ja, das liegt daran, dass das so eine Art
Franchise, was eigentlich in Deutschland verboten
ist, aber es ist so eine Art Franchise-Verein.
Das heißt, vor ein paar Jahren hat der Konzern
Red Bull, der ja auch schon in Österreich
und in anderen Ländern Vereine und Fußballvereine
unterstützt stark finanziell und die hochputscht,
hat einen kleineren Verein in Leipzig mehr
oder weniger übernommen und hat den Verein
umbenannt in RB. Also es soll natürlich für
Red Bull stehen, aber weil das nach deutschem
Vereinsrecht verboten ist oder nach Bundesligarecht,
haben die den halt, "RasenBallsport Leipzig"
heißt das dann oder "Rasenball Leipzig",
ich weiß es gerade nicht genau, genannt und
haben den halt innerhalb von wenigen Jahren
durch viel Geld nach oben gebracht in die
erste Liga. Und das passt natürlich vielen
nicht, die … vor allen Dingen für die vielen
Fans von traditionelleren Vereinen und dass
man sich halt Erfolg kaufen kann.
Was sagst du dazu persönlich?
Ich kann das total verstehen, dass man die
nicht mag, von daher.
Manuel, Alfonso schreibt: "In einer Episode
hast du eine peinliche Erfahrung gemacht,
als du einen relativ bekannten Fußballer
interviewt hast." Stimmt das?
Ja, ja, als ich das Praktikum beim Fernsehen
gemacht habe. Und seine Frage ist: "Wer war
das?" Und ich kann es dir nicht sagen. Ich
glaube, ich habe diese Erfahrung komplett
ausgeblendet aus meinem Gehirn.
Stimmt. So, da hat gerade Enno geschrieben.
Das ist ja ein Zufall. Dein Sohn heißt ja
auch Enno, Klaus. Und Enno schreibt: "Wann
nimmst du mich mal mit ins Stadion?"
Ich würde sagen, sobald es wieder geht.
Ja. Also Enno war noch nicht mit im Stadion?
Nee, bisher noch nicht und jetzt ging es ja
in dem letzten halben Jahr auch schlecht und
ich glaube, es wird bald Zeit. Also Enno,
wenn du das siehst und hörst, was du ja tust:
Ich glaube, im nächsten Jahr, wenn es wieder
geht, dann ist es soweit.
Das war ein Versprechen, Enno. Ja, und zwar
haben Andrés und Alice geschrieben. Sie sollen,
sie sagen uns "Hallo", unsere lieben Freunde.
Wir winken euch mal, Andrés und Alice. Jeremiah
hat gefragt: "Manuel, hast du Fußball gespielt?"
Hast du schon beantwortet, ein bisschen.
Ja, nicht wirklich. Ich bin dann klettern
gegangen. Ich mag mehr so Individualsport.
Passt auch zu der Frage von Juan. Juan möchte
wissen: "Was ist denn der zweithäufigste
Sport?" Ist denn Fußball wirklich der populärste
Sport in Deutschland?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also, es gibt, glaube
ich, in Deutschland über sechs Millionen,
sechseinhalb Millionen organisierte Fußballspielerinnen
und -spieler. Es gibt keinen anderen Sport
…
Sechseinhalb Millionen?
Genau, das sind, ja, was, ja. (Acht Prozent?)
Sieben, acht Prozent, genau. Und es gibt,
fast jeder Sportverein oder jedes Dorf, jede
Milchkanne, sagt man ja auch, hat einen Sportverein,
der Fußball anbietet. Und das gibt es halt
bei keiner anderen Sportart in Deutschland.
Und Hala hat auch geschrieben: "Außer Fußball,
welche anderen Sportarten mögen Deutsche?"
Also, es gibt eigentlich nichts Vergleichbares
oder? Tennis. Boxen.
Genau. Alles, was danach kommt, ist halt viel
kleiner und es sind dann manchmal auch so
Wellenbewegungen. Tennis war in den achtziger
Jahren riesengroß durch vor allen Dingen
die Erfolge von Boris Becker und Steffi Graf.
Dann war in den Zweitausendern Handball auch
ziemlich groß, weil wir da auch eine erfolgreiche
Nationalmannschaft der Männer und Frauen
hatten. Dann, was gab es noch für Sportarten,
die … hier, natürlich, du hast ja schon
gesagt: Du bist für Formel 1-Rennen aufgestanden.
Das war natürlich auch vor Jahren mit Vettel
oder davor mit Michael Schumacher auch natürlich
riesengroß, aber das nimmt dann natürlich
wieder ab, wenn die Deutschen nicht mehr so
erfolgreich sind.
Hier ist eine sehr schöne Frage. Und zwar
schreibt Keggy… Keggythekek schreibt: "Ich
möchte ein Fußballteam adoptieren — also
er oder sie möchte Fan werden in Deutschland
— was ist das schlechteste Team in Deutschland?
Das wird mein Team."
Ah! Okay, diese Frage finde ich sehr sympathisch,
weil ich möchte mal kurz erklären, dass
viele Menschen, also eigentlich alle, die
nicht ein Fan von dieser Mannschaft sind,
das Team Bayern München — von dem du ja
Fan warst, Cari — hassen. Und ich glaube,
dieser Hass rührt auch daher, dass sie so
erfolgreich sind, oder? Also, sie haben ja
so ung… also, selbst ich weiß, dass die
ständig immer alles gewinnen und das seit
Jahrzehnten. Und das ist irgendwie unsympathisch,
ne? Niemand mag so jemanden, der immer nur
gewinnt, oder?
Richtig, das ist, weil es ist unsympathisch
und wenn man zu erfolgsverwöhnt ist, kommt
halt noch Arroganz dazu und man nimmt die
anderen nicht mehr so ernst. Es fehlt der
Respekt und das trifft in vielen Phasen auch
auf den FC Bayern München zu.
Also sollte Keggythekek ein Bayern-Fan werden?
Ist das … (Nee.) Ist das euer Vorschlag?
Nicht Bayern, sondern halt irgendein kleines,
nicht so erfolgreiches Team suchen.
Zur Zeit wäre das FC Schalke, also.
Ja, aber …
Das ist der schlechteste Verein im Moment
in der ersten Liga?
In der ersten, in der ersten Bundesliga, ja.
Haben noch nicht gewonnen diese Saison, aber
kein Grund, Schalke-Fan zu werden. Also ich
kann natürlich nur den SV Meppen, hier ist
das Wappen, nur den SV Meppen natürlich ganz
stark hier empfehlen, ein wirklich toller
regionaler Verein. Der ist jetzt nicht unbedingt
so erfolgreich, ist aber aufgestiegen vor
zwei Jahren und der, also, es lohnt sich auf
jeden Fall, den SV Meppen zu unterstützen
— ich sage es noch mal — wo Maradona sein
erstes Spiel in Europa gemacht hat.
Fantastisch, Klaus. Yasmin schreibt uns aus
Brasilien und sie möchte gerne wissen: "Reden
die Deutschen noch oft über 2014, das legendäre
Spiel gegen Brasilien?" Klaus, was sagst du
dazu? Reden wir da jeden Tag drüber?
Was ist da passiert? Da haben wir, glaube
ich, ganz viele Tore geschossen, richtig?
Richtig, genau. Es war das legendäre Sieben-zu-Eins
gegen Brasilien im Halbfinale. Ich, also nicht
jeden Tag, aber so ab und an kommt das doch
schon mal wieder auf den Tisch. Ich weiß
noch, wo wir das geguckt haben, Cari. Das
haben wir nämlich zusammen geguckt damals,
das legendäre Spiel.
Stimmt, wir waren zusammen, ne?
Ja, und zwar in der Aula vom Schiller-Gymnasium.
Du erinnerst dich.
Ja. Wir haben getanzt, danach sind wir auf
die Straße gegangen. Es war eine große Party
in Deutschland, muss man sagen, vielleicht
die größte Fußball-Party meines Lebens.
Danach haben wir ja noch gewonnen, aber ich
muss sagen, dieses, dieser Sieg, dieser hohe
Sieg, der ja so unerwartet war, ich glaube,
das war noch eine größere Überraschung
als alles andere vorher und das war eine richtig
geile Party. Ja, wir erinnern uns daran. Klaus,
hier kommt eine Frage noch mal von Mustafa:
"Magst du Jürgen Klopp?"
Ja, definitiv.
Jetzt musst du noch erklären: Wer ist Jürgen
Klopp? Für Manuel.
Genau. Wollte gerade fragen: Wer ist das?
Jürgen Klopp ist ein deutscher, ehemaliger
Fußballspieler und aktueller Fußballtrainer.
Der hat zum Beispiel den FSV Mainz trainiert,
dann … auch sehr erfolgreich, dann sehr,
sehr erfolgreich Borussia Dortmund, zum Beispiel
mit dem Gewinn von zwei Meisterschaften und
auch Champions League-Finale. Und dann ist
er gewechselt nach England zum FC Liverpool
und auch dort ist er sehr erfolgreich. Hat
zum Beispiel dort die Champions League dann
gewonnen und hat jetzt auch die Meisterschaft,
die englische Meisterschaft gewonnen.
Ist ein, ist in, in England ist der super
populär und super bekannt, oder? Der Kloppo.
Der kommt halt auch sehr gut rüber, ist sehr
telegen, sehr medienaffin und …
Telegen.
Ja, also der lacht viel, der ist sehr optimistisch,
sympathisch kommt der rüber, aber das ist
halt so, ne? Ich glaube, viele finden den
total super. Es gibt dann aber auch welche,
die den dann genau deswegen halt nicht mögen,
aber ich finde ihn super. Ja.
Dann eine ganz praktische Frage: Wenn man
in Deutschland ins Stadion gehen möchte,
fragt Rafael, was kostet denn so eine Karte?
Ein Ticket fürs Spiel?
Manuel? Nein.
Ja, ich tippe mal, also, ich tippe, darf ich
tippen? Ich vermute mal, es geht los bei zwanzig,
dreißig Euro und wenn man aber die geilsten
VIP-Plätze will, dann fünftausend Euro.
Ja, im Grunde passt das, glaube ich, ganz
gut. Also, es gibt bei vielen Vereinen erst
mal sowieso Probleme, dass du überhaupt noch
Karten kriegst, weil gerade so die beliebten
Vereine wie zum Beispiel Dortmund, Schalke,
Bayern und so weiter, da ist es total schwierig,
überhaupt Karten für ein Spiel zu bekommen.
Und die günstigsten Plätze sind ja die Stehplätze
und die gehen tatsächlich so bei zwanzig,
glaube ich, fünfundzwanzig Euro los. Und
dann gibt es Sitzplatz-Kategorien ganz unterschiedlicher
Art, von fünfunddreißig Euro aufwärts bis
keine Ahnung was, hundertfünfzig Euro irgendwas.
Und tatsächlich die VIP-Plätze mit Bewirtung
und eigener Loge und VIP-Raum und so weiter
und die kosten natürlich dann wahrscheinlich
den Preis, den du gerade gesagt hast.
Haben wir noch Zeit für die zwei letzten
Fragen? Was sagt ihr?
Ja, klar.
Und zwar haben wir noch eine Fra… zwei Fragen
von Bruno, sehe ich gerade. Vielleicht kann
man die auch zusammen beantworten. Es geht
um die deutsche Nationalmannschaft, Klaus.
Ist diese deutsche Nationalmannschaft wichtig
für die Deutschen? Das ist eine einfache
Frage, oder? Und was ist deine Meinung über
Joachim Löw, unseren Bundestrainer, der gefühlt
schon seit fünfzig Jahren die deutsche Nationalmannschaft
trainiert?
Ja, also, klar, die Nationalmannschaft ist
alle zwei Jahre sehr wichtig, nämlich immer,
wenn große Turniere sind. Dazwischen meistens
nicht ganz so wichtig, aber es ist auf jeden
Fall immer Thema, aber wir hatten uns ja auch
schon mal darüber unterhalten. So ein bisschen
ist die große Liebe der Deutschen zur Nationalmannschaft,
ist gerade so ein bisschen erkaltet. Also,
ist gerade so ein bisschen Beziehungspause,
könnte man sagen. Und das wird sich auch
wahrscheinlich bis zum nächsten Turnier dann
doch ein bisschen wieder entwickeln, weil
die Nationalmannschaft, man sagt, ist in einer
Umbruchphase. Das heißt, viele alte, erfolgreiche
Spieler sind jetzt erst mal nicht mehr dabei,
viele neue, junge Spieler müssen sich erst
finden. Und das wird halt gerade auch von
Joachim Löw gemacht, der ja der Trainer der
Nationalmannschaft ist und ja. Also, grundsätzlich
ein sympathischer Typ und ist natürlich auch
ein sehr erfolgreicher Trainer. Es ist halt
immer so der Punkt, ob man nicht irgendwann
sagt, dass man auch mal sich eine neue Herausforderung
sucht und jemand anderem die Position übergibt,
weil es ist immer das Problem, wenn man zu
lange so eine Position hält, dann kann es
sein, dass man irgendwann, den Z… hier,
wie heißt das? Den Zeitpunkt des richtigen
Absprungs verpasst hat.
Ja, Joachim Löw ist ja im Prinzip so wie
Angela Merkel, ist schon so verwachsen in
Deutschland. Er ist ein fester Bestandteil.
Die Menschen haben sich an ihn gewöhnt. Wisst
ihr denn, wie lange er schon Bundestrainer
ist? Eine Schätzfrage an euch.
Ich glaube kürzer, als Merkel Bundeskanzlerin
ist. Ich würde mal so tippen dreizehn Jahre
oder so, kann das sein?
Klaus?
Er ist genau ein Jahr lang kürzer Bundestrainer
als Merkel Kanzlerin ist.
Ah ja.
Ja, da hat der Manuel doch recht. (Ja genau,
ja.) Vierzehn Jahre.
Vierzehn Jahre.
Richtig, seit 2006, ja.
Ja. Das wird, da wird eine Ära zu Ende gehen,
wenn Merkel und Löw …
… im nächsten Jahr …
… gemeinsam in den Ruhestand gehen.
Deutschland ist führungslos.
Ja, das war doch ein gelungenes Ende zu unserer
… War viel zu kurz, ne? Aber vielleicht
können wir uns ja in Zukunft noch mal unterhalten,
Klaus. Wärst du noch mal bereit, zurückzukommen?
Ja klar, sehr gerne.
Und wollen wir uns die zwei Minuten noch nehmen
für Klaus' Empfehlungen? Die finde ich nämlich
wirklich spannend.
Stimmt, die hatten wir fast vergessen.
Genau. Ja, ich habe …
Empfehlungen der Woche: Schlusskonferenz und
11FREUNDE
Schieß los.
Daran merkt man, dass ich kein Profi bin.
Ja, ich habe, ich habe nur zwei Sachen rausgesucht,
die ich, die ich ganz gut finde. Das eine
ist ein Podcast, den man hören kann, wenn
man sich für die, vor allen Dingen für die
Bundesliga interessiert, und zwar heißt der
Podcast "Schlusskonferenz" und da werden nach
jedem Bundesligaspieltag, sonntags kommt das
meistens raus, wird noch mal der Spieltag
besprochen. Ist sehr informativ, ist aber
natürlich schon etwas, was so ein bisschen
sehr für Fußballbegeisterte ist. Da wird
noch mal tief in die Materie hineingetaucht,
aber auch auf eine sehr humorvolle und amüsante
Art und Weise. Also das ist die "Schlusskonferenz".
Der Kanal heißt "Rasenfunk", aber das können
wir ja dann in die Show Notes reinschreiben.
Genau, wir verlinken das unter dem Video und
in den Show Notes vom Podcast.
Genau. Und das zweite, das ist ein Fußballmagazin,
also eine Zeitschrift, die heißt "11FREUNDE",
also elf Freunde, wie die Spieler einer Mannschaft.
Und das ist, glaube ich, in Deutschland mittlerweile
das beliebteste Fußballmagazin. Das kommt
einmal im Monat raus, hat tolle Interviews,
interessante Fakten, Hintergrundberichte und
immer ein Schwerpunktthema, was die in dem
Magazin dann vorstellen. Und das kann man
richtig gut lesen, also, kann ich auch sehr
gut empfehlen.
Toll. Werde ich mir nicht anschauen, aber
ich freue mich trotzdem für alle, die sich
das anschauen werden.
Ich habe für die, warte mal, wo ist es denn?
Hier. Für die Leute, die es interessiert.
Das habe ich nämlich gerade geschenkt bekommen
von Ursula. Das ist ein Kalender mit den Covern
der letzten Jahre von "11FREUNDE". So sieht
es aus, ne? Das kann man sich dann mal angucken.
Jetzt hast du es doch gesehen, Manuel.
Manuel wird sich es nicht angucken, aber das
sind doch gute Tipps für alle Menschen, die
Deutsch lernen und sich für Fußball interessieren.
Klaus, danke, dass du dir heute die Zeit genommen
hast mit uns. (Sehr gerne.) Man muss dazu
sagen, du hattest gestern einen runden Geburtstag.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch von der Easy German
Community noch mal. Wenn ihr Klaus gratulieren
wollt, schreibt uns einen Kommentar hier unten.
Danke, dass du dabei warst, Klaus. Es hat
uns sehr bereichert, denn alleine hätten
Manuel und ich das heute nicht geschafft.
Ja, es hat wieder sehr viel Spaß gemacht
und wir haben ja immer nur an der Oberfläche
gekratzt, ne, aber wir können ja noch mal
zurückkommen.
Wir machen auf jeden Fall einen Teil zwei.
Genau. Schreibt uns eure Fragen hier unten,
wenn ihr noch Fragen habt, dann werden wir
vielleicht noch mal einen Teil zwei machen.
Und werdet gerne ein Mitglied von Easy German,
denn als Podcast-Mitglied bekommt ihr nämlich
zu dieser Episode auch ein Transkript mit
einem interaktiven Transkript-Player und ihr
hört noch Outtakes zu jeder Episode. Da werden
wir uns gleich darüber unterhalten, wie denn
diese Sendung heute gelaufen ist und wer Klaus'
Lieblingsfußballer ist.
Ja.
Danke schön fürs Zuhören und Zusehen!
Danke, Klaus!
Danke euch. Viele Grüße!
Tschüss ihr beiden.
Ciao.